happy one-year anniversary overwatch
it feels like just yesterday we were
logging onto your servers picking out
our favorite hero and getting mowed down
by Bastion and over the last 12 months
Blizzard has done everything you can
imagine to please a player base of 30
million including seasonal events short
films and even its very own eSports
League but in that same time so many
things about the game have changed so
what I want to do was go through the
past year's timeline and grave Blizzard
on how they've handled the games gradual
transformation and give them a report
card that can show their parents later
now if you need a reminder of all the
updates that overwatch is had you can
check out all the live streams erik tan
i've done for some loot box shenanigans
or you can check out the hero guys for
all the new characters but if you're
ready to go let's recap Oh
as we all know we have three heroes
bestowed upon a star in the past year
all three of which are impeccably
designed fitting right into the world
and it's establish lore
first we were given an ax the healing
sniper with an amazing set of tools then
a few months later
Sombra was revealed to the planet and we
are all excited to play as a stealth
character and hack everything in sight
and finally after some doofus rumors
that were no doubt magnified by Terry
Crews visit to the Blizzard campus we
met IRISA the new Bonnie robot designed
to protect each why these heroes has
pushed the story forward injecting life
not only into the overwatch universe but
also the game's meta and even with onna
currently being used way more than
somber under erisa all three still feel
useful and most importantly of all fun
to play Blizzard also introduced three
brand-new maps as well
there was echo point Antarctica which
was mostly relegated to a 3v3 arena and
is actually somewhat of a bore to look
at but the other two maps Oasis and I
convolve are both absolutely gorgeous
if I had any gripes it'd probably be
with the way sombras reveal was handled
now I like alternate reality games just
as much as the next person but blizzards
decision to draw the reveal all four
months going from one fake website to
another with timer after timer counting
down to nothing with no end in sight it
just kind of tired everyone out after a
while it just wasn't fun anymore and
people just bleeding for it to end so
far over watches new heroes and maps it
gets a B+ for me and I just hope
Blizzard can keep the future releases
just as hype one thing they I'm sure a
lot of us were hoping for this past year
was a single-player mode of sorts
anything that would further detail
overwatch a story line but Blizzard seem
to be content on doing their own thing
and delivering the characters
backstories very very gradually through
short films comics and blog posts I
think this is probably the smarter way
to go about things as it keeps players
interested and lets each new story
update soak in the game does have a lot
to work with but I would personally love
to see more plot based seasonal events
you know stuff like the uprising event
that is canned into the overwatch
universe but until then
overwatch gets a B+ in the story
Department there's little doubt that
Blizzard has been hitting it way out of
the park with their seasonal events the
summer games Halloween terror winter
wonderland year the rooster and uprising
have each displayed blizzards strengths
in creating exciting events each one has
given players new skins emote swing
poses sprays as well as fun arcade modes
that showcase just how well the game can
morph into different styles okay maybe I
could have done without the turtle fest
that was capture the flag but joking
sans revenge was pretty spectacular and
the holiday-themed masks were a joy to
play
Jamison Junkins time overall it's an
a-minus balancing is tough work just ask
this guy right here within the first few
months of release we are all realizing
just how overpowered McCree was so
Blizzard took away his ability to kill
tanks with his fan the hammer now it
seems like it would be a mistake for
them to let that slip through but it's a
perfect example of how a where Blizzard
is about the balance in their game
overall I feel like Blizzard has done an
exceptional job with one of the hardest
aspects in competitive games nearly
every character has been tweaked to a
point where it doesn't feel embarrassing
for you to play them yes Winston I'm
looking at you it's a constant balancing
act to keep 24 different characters on
the same level and it's only going to
get harder as they add more heroes to
the mix but even complete overhauls two
characters designs have worked pretty
well in their favor
for example Symetra who is possibly the
most under played hero for the first six
months was transformed into a powerful
and in some cases essential character
all while retaining everything that made
her fun to play to begin with like the
cleaning of a house balance changes
never end so while we're looking to the
future and hoping Blizzard doesn't screw
up our favorite heroes for now they get
an a-minus
while it's not necessarily something
that Blizzard Institute themselves I
think the most important thing that has
risen out of overwatch is existence is
the fandom even during the beta before
the official release of the game people
were discovering the personalities of
the heroes and there was just enough
mystery behind each of their stories for
fans to fill in the blanks and fill in
they did everywhere you turn there were
people making fan art creating cosplay
making tutorials but the best part about
the community effort is that Blizzard
has embraced it all wholeheartedly they
understand the importance of fans
finding their own fun with the world
they've created and they just let the
people do it
Hanzo mains want to be the butt of all
jokes sure Blizzard will play along and
especially we want to dedicate this to
all the Hanzo names out there in just 12
short months the community has greatly
influenced how overwatch and characters
are seen outside the game which is
something that not many games can claim
in their favor hell they've even turned
blizzards own Jeff Kaplan into a
creation of their
oan is there anyone out there who
doesn't look at him and immediately here
to pick one from the 1 to the 3 what's
up this is Jeff from the overwatch team
it's hard to say just how much of
overwatch is success can be attributed
to the community but it's top-notch
character and level design attractive
art style and ridiculously charismatic
voice actors have captured the attention
of 30 million pairs of eyes it's been
one of the most inspiring creative and
enjoyable communities to be a part of
and for that overwatch is community
presence gives a big fat a plus
ultimately with all that Blizzard has
done for the game I'm giving overwatch
his first year in a it's astounding just
how much quality content they've given
players they kept it fun exciting and
consistently engaging they've managed to
give us a game whose story celebrates
all walks of life whose community has
embraced his characters and world with
open arms and whose gameplay in the face
of the ever-changing competitive
landscape offers a satisfying and
balanced experience so overwatch thanks
for the first year and here's to another
year or two or ten let's keep it going
hey everyone thanks for watching I hope
you all had a great first year with
overwatch - I had a lot of fun making
this video and if you enjoyed it please
leave a like or subscribe to our channel
to show your support I really appreciate
it and if you have any great overwatch
memories that you guys want to share
please leave them in the comments below
and I'll see you next time
[Music]